[Music]
my name is nari sol i'm a pianist
composer and i'd like to bring you along
with me as i learn more about
argentine tango i come from the
classical music tradition and
periodically i spend time immersing
myself
in a new genre what attracts me to tango
is the emotional quality of the music
and its unique pacing
[Music]
it's fiery yet a bit restrained rigid
yet
flexible and very balanced for this
video i got to speak with many tango
specialists and if you stick around
until the end you can hear
a piece i wrote as a tribute to this
whole experience
that is necessary somewhere are the many
different types of tangos argentine
tango is one of the original forms of
the dance and music
and in order to understand its roots it
helps to get
a picture of the developing scene in
argentina throughout the 19th
and 20th centuries
its capital city buenos aires exploded
in population
as immigrants rushed in from all over
the world this created a melting pot of
cultures including those from africa
spain italy england poland
and russia as the traditional dances
from all of these different cultures
mixed together
the earliest forms of tango came to
being this is why the tango has elements
of traditional european polkas
waltzes polish berserkers cuban
habaneras
and condoms rhythms from africa
[Music]
understanding the social culture and
dance is crucial to understanding the
core of tango
[Music]
the roots are very social and it's
in some way kind of an intuitive
dance
[Music]
the key is to get that connection
between the brains of two people
and you've got to decide one of them has
got a legion one of them has got to
follow
we need a fixed structure for play to
dancers
that use a choreography if the dancer
don't use a choreography
you don't need fixed structures
[Music]
flores
[Music]
he organized tango in tango milonga
and balls every person has a different
point of view about this
mainly you have like two styles the
social dance
and the stage tango
something that sticks out to me is that
there's a certain kind of intensity
behind
each note when you think of the straight
quarter notes there's a lot behind it
there's a lot of fire elegance restraint
and this desire that you can feel and
that's what makes the tango and this
kind of thing
is really hard to pick up from just
looking at a score
and almost like percussive i'm playing
that and doing this with my my feet we
don't have
a unique way to play tango we have
a lot of ways and we need to combine and
to know different ways
only marcato
[Music]
just four equally accented quarter notes
it's very simple really
and then you have another one that we
call it cinco ba
two eighth notes quarter note rest
quarter note corner rest
usually the arranger can go to town like
changing the order
or changing you know keys usually what
you do is
you do the song as pure as you can at
the very beginning and then when you
have to repeat the a
or something like that you allow
yourself a little more elaboration
do you also improvise when you're
playing tango you can improvise
when playing tango but it's just in very
narrow spaces
tango never took that step
towards improvisation that jazz did and
you can improvise
some ornaments it's more like barak
improvisation if anything
we have the rhythmic melodics and the
expressive melodies
with a lot of articulations we have
another word
[Music]
you know okay that is a not rhythmic
melody
it's
[Music]
the harmonies and structures found in
traditional tangos are not very
different than the basic chord
progressions found in many european folk
songs
waltzes polkas and just pretty much
many other genres many are based around
the typical pillars of
tonal harmony
the push and pull between the tonic and
dominant are usually clearly
present as you can hear
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in general you'll find two types of
arrangements the larger orchestra typica
[Music]
and the smaller ensembles with the
[Music]
guitar
they have different rules because the
guitar is not part
of the orchestrative
one instrument closely related to tango
music is the bandonian which is
currently one of my favorite
instruments another cliche would be to
say that the evandonion is like the soul
of
tango this was invented in 1854 in
germany to play
religious music it used to be called
bandonium
and i understand that very many sailors
play this instrument and that's the
reason how it got to argentina
and and they start playing this
instrument in the in the
houses but the italian accordion players
quickly adapted this instrument to play
tango because
it had a very sad sound it had like a
velvet sound
the accordion has like a happy sound and
this instrument
has really nothing happy in it
[Music]
so of course when talking about modern
tango we must mention astor piazzolla
[Music]
it's it's my favorite some people
might say he's not tango to me it's
tango
my window into the music was piazzolla
he lived
in new york for a little while and he
started with nadia
in paris and such so he started doing a
lot of modal stuff
and that was the revolution for camera
because tango is
super tonal what first got me into tango
music was astor piazzolla as well
his music is performed often by
classical musicians
but i think a lot of times the
interpretation of his music
is a bit misinformed one tango tip i'm
going to give for all classical
musicians out there
if you have four quarter notes that
resemble
a walking bass on the left hand these
are never staccato
so it's kind of drummy in a way the
moment you start doing like
you lose all the groove halfway into
this journey i started writing my
tribute piece to tango
combining elements of what i've been
learning as well as
my personal style of composition
so i came up with this theme while
playing around on two mini keyboards
i was really looking for a melody that
is singable somewhat danceable and can
be elaborated on
and dotted notes seem pretty appropriate
for tingo so i included
plenty of those as well as of course a
lot of straight marcato
quarter notes and syncopation from there
i did some improvisation
on the piano just to try out potential
directions for the piece
[Music]
modern music we have a lot of work to do
i don't know if it should be or
so writing it was way more
straightforward than understanding the
best way to perform it which brings me
now to articulations and expression
this is what seems to me the most
fundamental component behind
what makes something sound like tango or
not if i play a chocolate in that way
all the notes equal like
[Music]
that's good are the notes but this is
not a tangle
you need to put accents
can you do it one more time tango tango
tango
tango yeah there you go yeah yeah yeah
there's something special about the
temple as well
whether it's fast or slow there's a lot
of confidence and poise behind it
tango can be fast but it's never rushed
since we don't have
drums the tempo is very flexible
[Music]
[Applause]
the tempo is like a big gelatin
[Music]
if they speed up and slow down too
radically it's just hard to keep the
connection it's going to be annoying to
dance to they're too mechanical again
they're not danceful
[Music]
here is a little experiment that i
started many months ago
with beethoven's diabetes variation
because beethoven loved
tango numbers i just thought that his
theme from his diabetes variations
could be a nice starting point to try
applying different
rhythmic and harmonic concepts
i'm just using that so as you can see
very simple about six months ago i wrote
this very
bare bones arrangement
okay so it's really basic but the key
point here is that i compress the notes
so that there is a dotted rhythm present
now
and now fast forward to today i did
another pass at this
using some of the things that i learned
still not that close but
maybe closer now i especially made sure
to add a lot more variety
[Music]
at this point i started putting a lot of
the things that i've been learning into
practice which was helping me understand
how to
better pace the performance of my piece
i read through some excerpts of
traditional tangos here's one that pablo
arranged
and i continued to listen to a lot of
music from the different eras and styles
of tango
as well as some that are mixed in with
other genres
i was really just having fun immersing
myself in this world for a bit
and i think these things help me finish
writing my tango yes
and now i'd like to finally share with
you my piece for solo piano
called first tango
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
i really like it the first part i can
dance it without knowing the
music the second part was difficult
sorry
i couldn't continue
[Music]
i really imagining this part is like
something that i see on the stage
that the music that i can see dance
dancing in a stage
thank you to all of the wonderful
musicians and dancers that helped me
make this video
more information about them will be in
the description and a special thank you
to all of my patrons on patreon
thank you all for watching and sharing
this video and if you'd like to see more
like this
check out my genres playlist where i've
previously covered genres like
bossa nova flamenco pop and bebop